welcome back this is the Benton
Shapiro's chart number eight five five
two three six thirty two twenty eight
eight five five two three six and thirty
two twenty eight taking your calls
because we are hanging out together
marking Adamsville Indiana on the bench
pair of golf art mark I've been any
question with all of the coronavirus log
down stuff going on and I'm sure you've
read about the police ticketing people
in Kentucky for going to church services
I've read a lot of sentiment online
where you know people are basically
siding with the with the police and
saying this is this is okay
you know you have extremes on both sides
but you know my opinion of it is is you
know Nazi Germany they were following
orders whenever they're asking people
for papers that doesn't make it right
do you think that you know this country
has gone too far
and we can we turn it back around us so
you know what would you say to the
people that are that are agreeing with
these policies saying hey I just saying
aside I mean you know I never I never
liked making yeah I mean merica I never
liked making nazi comparisons just
because the Nazis were also engaged in
tremendous human rights violations
including mass murder of human beings
when it comes to petty authoritarianism
when it comes to petty authoritarians at
the local level who are using the
opportunity of a lockdown to sort of
flex their muscle giving people thousand
dollar fines for walking around on a
beach alone with no masks like come on
come on like that that that stuff
obviously ought to be out of bounds and
is ridiculous as far as the long-term
lockdown here I mean you can hear I've
been willing to grant a certain amount
of legitimacy to government doing this
stuff for public health benefit but they
need to spell out a plan they won't even
they won't to explain to us what kind of
data they are missing and I'm okay with
hearing the plan then we can debate the
plan we can talk about you know okay
what data do you need how long is it
gonna take to gather that data now we
need to balance out okay well how many
deaths versus versus what period of time
are we supposed to completely stop all
of American life and throw 30 million
people out of work and pay for
everybody's bills on the back of debt
that we're never gonna repay and inflate
out of those are all public policy
debates what what is making me insane is
the notion that we are all supposed to
give up our Liberty indefinitely without
any sort of plan for getting out of it
with
any sort of metrics for how we are even
supposed to tell when we get our
liberties back and without any sort of
understanding of the of the data itself
it's as though it's as though the
absence of data has become a cover for
the authoritarianism and then that's
when I start to go crazy now I will say
that I think that that president from
being the president has helped with a
lot of this because it is very obvious
that Trump does not want this lockdown
to go on for 10 seconds longer then is
than his usual right I mean he he
doesn't he does not want us to be
happening I I admit that I would be a
lot more suspicious of a Democrat were
in charge because the tendency there is
toward shutting down business and paying
people and transforming the nature of
American government Trump obviously does
not want to be in this situation so
maybe he is not making all the right
decisions maybe he needs better
information maybe he needs a more
nuanced take on how all of this works
but I at least don't suspect his motives
in in the middle of this logjam but as
this goes on I mean I was just noticing
the in Los Angeles right I was out of
the news for the last couple of days I
was noticing that Eric Garcetti the
mayor of LA put his stay at a home order
on the books until May 15th and I'm just
thinking to myself based on what data
like what how are you even doing that
based on what data like at that point I
start to think to myself no May first
people are gonna start to go back to
work people are gonna start ignoring
this stuff because people won't people
can only wrote quote unquote rely on the
experts as long as they feel like the
experts either one know more than they
do or to have a plan for knowing more
than they do right now it doesn't feel
like the experts know significantly more
than they do and it doesn't seem like
experts have a plan for knowing more
than they do so people are I think
correctly getting upset with all of this
which should spur the experts to come up
with some better metrics for how we
figure out how to get out of this thing
and what a plan looks like and they
better do that in short order because I
promise you that the longer they go with
the trust us routine and the longer
Americans are saying we'll hold on my
life's work has been put on hold I'm
supposed to just sit home with my kids
and shelter in place until when 18
months from now when there's supposedly
a vaccine
hey what no no buying into buying in as
a stay at home this can save lives and
they're just giving up their freedoms no
questions asked and that's what really
concerns me you know that alone I think
you know people
I understand people buying these stay at
home to save lives for now because
that's true it is saving lives in the
here and now the question is over the
long
term is it gonna save lives and we need
data on that like ASAP and if that data
isn't forthcoming eventually people are
gonna get just tired of this I mean my
parents are 65 64 65 and and they are
basically ready to walk out of the house
now basically you need to stay at home
but you know it's like at what cost
because there's a lot of different
different data out there you know you
read about causes of death being
attributed to kovat when it's really
something else
so there's a lot of conflicting data out
there as well and you know just what
really concerns me is all this
information or a lot of people that are
just accepting and saying hey we need to
do this this is you know I believe Ben
Franklin I think the problem is you know
market again I think that the problem is
that people who are saying we need to do
this are not adding the words for now if
they add the words for now I'm like okay
understandable if they're just saying we
need to do this period then I think they
fundamentally misunderstand what exactly
the information is out there which is
that the minute that we go out there and
we start associating with each other
there will be hotspots again there will
be people who are infected there will be
a second wave of infections and and
that's what what I have ejected to all
long in these models is they keep saying
well 61,000 dead if we really hold to
this yeah by August first and then the
model don't continue beyond August first
what the hell are you talking about mark
really appreciate the problem definitely
appreciate the concern
yakov calling all the way from israel
you're on the bench bureaus right how's
it going yo I've been Cox I'm asking
your family oh well so I want to know
you talked a lot about how the death
rate as I the infection rate is probably
a lot higher than you know the confirmed
cases it's that so then wouldn't that
send the death rate you know plummeting
giving us more reason to be hopeful and
you know less scared and if that's the
case doesn't that would that mean that
we like will be able to leave lift
restrictions sooner than we had
originally thought that's sort of the
hope right I mean I've been I've been
wondering all along whether this case
fatality rate is wildly inflated and
also how it adjusts for population right
now is it adjusted for age is it
adjusted for pre-existing condition
because we are gonna have to transfer
pretend that we're gonna treat a 30 year
old healthy person the same way we treat
an 80 / 80 year old person who's already
had radiation therapy for cancer is is
just idiotic like that
that's not a real thing and it's also a
big difference between weather case pay
if case fatality rate is three point
five four percent in reality and this
thing is highly transmissible then you
do have to talk about okay exactly how
do we continue to operate as a society
and I think much more restrictive ways
than if the case fatality rate is 0.3%
and it's three times as deadly as the
flu but a lot more transmissible and
when you get to younger populations it's
basically as deadly as the flu but more
transmissible right then you're just
talking about social distancing and
don't go to big crowds and wash your
hands a lot and don't touch your face I
mean that's really what you're talking
about so yeah I mean I've been urging
day to day to day and frankly I'm
shocked the federal government has not
rolled out any plans to put forth data
that state governments have not rolled
out any plans it's basically been left
to private institutions to do this sort
of data mining I mean I know a couple of
different people who are working hard on
putting together private data studies
how is it the government's haven't made
this top priority so they can even
analyze what are the factors that go
into the decision-making yaakov it's
crazy you know I have to ask you Israel
has been completely locked down during
Passover for those in Israel not only
locked down they basically lock you in
your house we weren't allowed to go
outside you weren't allowed to go to
anybody else's they were afraid of going
to somebody else to Seder yeah so what
is this now it's called a mode over
there right look at this very strange
obviously Israel is at its you know peak
of livelihood and everyone's active
during collenberg pesos Passover and now
it's just completely dead you know you
yes you can't leave your house without a
mask on only essential reasons you know
I left my house today for the first time
in a month to go to pick up my sister
who's a soldier from Jerusalem so it's
very restricted it's you know you know
what you can't leave your house be
they're fine they're police everywhere
it's very strange
yeah I mean it's it is an incredible
situation across the globe yeah come
really appreciate your comment and hang
in there hope that you're having a
decent Passover despite all of this Alex
in Pennsylvania on the bench Bureau
she'll go for now it's hello Ben thank
you for having me again my question is
for you I don't really hear you talk
about this issue at all thing that's
Crowder but what is the conservative
view on the death penalty so the
conservative view on the death penalty
is that in principle there's nothing
wrong with the death penalty there are
questions about the application meaning
it is unevenly applied we don't actually
know when it is
Clyde but the idea that there are
certain people who deserve to die I
think is true without question I mean
people who rape and kill children should
die they have no right to to live they
they should not be breathing the same
air as the rest of us with that said you
know the general state application of
the death penalty has been incredibly
uneven it has been too sparse actually
if you're going to treat it as an actual
regular part of the criminal justice
system and that does raise questions
about whether it ought to be applied at
all if it's going to be applied so
unevenly Alex appreciate the call Leon
in Columbia you're at the bench Pete
you're on the bench professional go for
it Leon yeah you often talk about the
single-payer medicare system as being
completely evil and when Bernie brings
it up he goes and it's done more because
Denmark and you go and you point out
while they also have private health care
now I noticed that you never talk about
that those two-tier systems and why or
why not that couldn't work inside the
United States can you speak to that a
little bit so there is a two-tier system
in the United States right we do have
Medicaid we do have Medicare each of
emergency care right so if you walk into
an ER you will be treated and then you
have the ability to pay so the idea of a
two-tier system in which you have a
basic level of health care guaranteed
and then you have a secondary system in
which you can purchase better care that
actually exists in places like Singapore
and I've mentioned Singapore as a
possible alternative to the United
States model it would actually be
clearer than the u.s. model since the
truth is that we are sort of filtering
public costs through private systems by
charging people who have private
insurance well downgrading people who
have you know Medicaid for example so
it's a very sort of we have a bizarre
mixed system one of the great lies about
America is that we have a highly
privatized system we have a privatized
system in some ways but the the vast
minority if not majority of people who
are getting health care have that
subsidized in some way by the federal
state or local government so that is
it's important to recognize that America
is indeed a mixed system and not a pure
private system before you even get into
should it be just a pure two-tier system
I think there's a case we made that if
you're going to have the government
involved at all the government should
basically cover basically only emergency
care if you wish to or if you wish to
you know pay out of pocket for other
care for for you know use for more
expensive care and that's something
you should go ahead and do and the most
most care should actually be points of
contact that if you want to pay out of
pocket for for a flu diagnosis they
should be able to do that without even
reference to insurance that seems like
that that might be worthwhile that's
something at least I am open to I
appreciate the call Liam
all righty coming up I'm gonna take more
of your calls at eight five five to
thirty six thirty to twenty eight that's
eight five five to thirty six thirty to
twenty eight